Here's an interesting media story. Another
Fox news reporter has quit. So we had Shepard
Smith quitting a few weeks ago. This time
it's Catherine Herridge, who certainly much
less well known than Shep Smith. Catherine
Herridge known more for holding up documents
in front of the camera. During her reports,
she has quit Fox news. And what's really funny
is that there are conflicting reports. She
used the term facts matter. She used it in
a statement that was released by her outgoing
employer, Fox news, and she used the term
facts matter in a statement by her new upcoming
employer, CBS news. She's going from Fox news
to CBS news. But what's very interesting is
that depending on which of the two statements
you read, the interpretation of facts matter
either can appear to be praise for Fox news
or an attack against Fox news.
Take a look at the two statements. So the
statement released via Fox news was, I have
received great personal satisfaction from
mentoring the next generation of reporters
and producers and sharing my journalistic
values that facts matter and enterprise reporting
will always win the day. This one seems to
imply that at Fox news she was able to share
her value that facts matter. Now when you
look at the CBS news statement from Catherine
Herridge, CBS news has always placed a premium
on enterprise journalism and powerful investigations.
I feel privileged to join a team where facts
and storytelling will always matter. Which
of course the second one is sort of suggesting
that at CBS news, facts always matter. But
where she's coming from at Fox news facts
did not always matter, which of course we
know now as far as Catherine heritage is concerned,
even if this is her taking a stand against
the propaganda echo chamber of Fox where facts
don't matter.
I mean, if she's not necessarily saying it,
I will. And most of you know that facts do
not matter at Fox news. I have a hard time
feeling super proud of this stand that she's
taking, if it is indeed what she's doing.
She's been there for a very long time. Nothing
has actually changed now on Fox news where
now it's clearly the right thing to do if
you care about facts to quit. But at some
point in the past, if you cared about facts,
it was okay to be at Fox news. And she's also
not a particularly recognizable face there
anyways. So I, I'm not going to, uh, you know,
make any, uh, positive, uh, assessments of
what she's doing here. But the interesting
story is a broader one about some of the Fox
news departures of the last couple of years.
So we had Megan Kelly starting sometime back
after a very public sort of dispute with then
candidate Trump.
Uh, we had Shep Smith more recently and then
you know, some smaller contributors like Catherine
Herridge who have just more quietly disappeared
from Fox news. But in the end, and this is
really the big story, Fox is still crushing
the ratings. There are some concerning numbers
that I'll tell you about in a moment, but
Fox news is still widely dominating the cable
news ratings. Now there's an argument to be
made that Fox news is the place for a particular
type of audience and therefore they're sort
of coalescing audiences that on the other
side are kind of split between a broader variety
of news outlets. That's the Madoff mathematical
argument, but you can't deny that they're
still widely crushing the ratings, the one
area where Fox is not doing so well. And this
may be interesting upcoming as we get into
the 2020 election. Adults 25 to 54 are considered
like the important demographic in the news
world.
Sometimes they're referred to as the demo,
the demographic that matters, foxes down 5%
in total primetime viewers this past October
compared to the previous October of 2018 they're
down 13% in total day viewers, they're down
25% in the primetime key demographic that
we're talking about, age 25 to 54 and they
are down 27% in the total day demographic
of adults, 25 to 54 so Fox is doing well,
they're beating out CNN, they're beating out
MSNBC at, at all, most, if not all times of
the day across the spectrum. But they are
having a growing problem with this important
key demographic of adults 25 to 54 now, fortunately
for them, them, it doesn't really matter,
right? They don't need to be profitable since
they have these rich right-wingers that fund
them. And that's going to continue, I won't
say in perpetuity because nothing lasts forever,
particularly in media, but for the foreseeable
future.
But this also connects to 2020 and it also
connects to the, the growing sort of rift
between Donald Trump and Fox news. On the
one hand, you have the folks like, you know,
Sean Hannity and Janine Pirro and I believe
Laura Ingram for the most part is on the Trump
train. They are effectively Trump Brown nosers
a functioning almost as state media on Fox
news on a daily basis. Jeanine Pirro on a
weekly basis, I think. But then you've got
people like Tucker Carlson who's not always
on the Trump train. You have Shep Smith, who
certainly wasn't and has now left. And Donald
Trump over the last year or 15 months as we've
been talking about, has been more and more
frequently promoting the even crazier alternative
to Fox news. Oh, a N or O a N N one American
news network. So this is going to be an interesting
media narrative heading into 2020.
Now remember in 2016 really 2015 when Fox
news was not behind Donald Trump, they were
not behind Trump in a less overtly, uh, problematic
way for the right because there were all sorts
of more establishment Republicans that they
could support or be behind Ted Cruz or Jeb
Bush or whoever, until eventually they got
behind Donald Trump. As it became clear he
was going to be the nominee. This time there
is less sort of plausible reasoning for Fox
news or right wing echo chamber, not to be
behind Trump because there is at least as
of yet no serious primary challenger to Donald
Trump. And it doesn't appear that there's
going to be one. So the circumstances would
be far different if Fox were not to be Holy
behind Trump as we get into the 2020 election.
I expect they will be, but I think there might
still be some interesting drama to be seen.
Let me know what you think about all of this.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman. The show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show. And another
reminder, Twitch live streams are back. I
did one on Sunday night. There will be one
or two more upcoming this week and you can
catch those@twitchdottvslashdavidtacklethedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakmandotcomthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com